these one of these things cold again a
graphics card we have a graphics card
I haven't welcome back to harbor unboxed
today we're revisiting the topic of
graphics card pricing also looking at a
new graphics card something we haven't
done in quite some time because of well
graphics card prices on hand I have the
new asrock rx 580 phantom gaming and
we'll put this thing through its paces
shortly for now though let's talk a bit
about the current market conditions it's
fair to say it's been a rough ride over
the past 6 to 12 months for those hoping
to build a new gaming PC or even a used
PC for that matter this time last year
though it was happier tires for PC
builders I mean sure ddr4 memory prices
were still quite high but today they're
almost 50% higher the most extreme
barrier to entry though for PC gamers
has of course been the graphics card and
I think 12 months ago you could have
quite easily picked up pretty much any
model for the MSRP and an rx 588
gigabyte for example well they were
selling for 230 dollars u.s. today
though cameras can only dream of those
kinds of prices don't know why I'm
laughing I think it's just so silly now
it's just a joke anyway by June prices
had already started to rise and before
long getting a gaming graphics card and
anywhere near the MSRP became a real
challenge by April 2017 the average rx
580 costs 260 dollars u.s. then 310
dollars by November and by January 2018
we were seeing pricing exceeds $600 US
more recently though is in the last
month we have started to see prices fall
back down as cryptocurrency mining cools
off for a bit and GPU mining for various
reasons becomes less appealing the
result has been a drop in price to 350
dollars u.s. which is still outrageous
but shockingly a big improvement from
where we were just a few short months
ago pricing for the geforce gtx 1066
gigabyte is similar though we are seeing
more models selling for around 320
dollars u.s.
even with a drop in demand for graphics
cards it's unlikely we're going to see
prices hit MSRP s as there's still that
whole mess with DRAM supply pushing
pricing up and as a result of what's
going on there Samsung micron and
hynek's are getting sued for alleged
DRAM price-fixing kick starting 2018 I
created a three part series titled why
building a gaming PC right now is a bad
idea and part two discussed a graphics
card pricing I predicted at the time
that this issue wouldn't rectify itself
till later in the year and as we
approach the midway point of 2018 that
ominous prediction is looking at more
and more accurate still things are
improving and if you've been desperately
waiting to get your hands on a graphics
card isn't the other time to give in and
pull the trigger
well honestly I'm not really sure if it
is or not personally though I'd probably
give it another month and spend that
time monitoring which direction the
prices are heading there's also the
issue of whether or not you should even
invest in a current generation GPU at
this point we are very deep into the
product cycle and are expecting new
price from both Nvidia and AMD before
years and despite a list though as
rocker recently threw their hat into the
ring by signing up to become an
exclusive AMD Radeon partner their new
phantom gaming series includes rx 550 rx
560 RX v 7t + RX 580 graphics cards and
they've sent over the flagship model the
RX 588 G phantom gaming XOC so more than
a year on since the refreshed Radeon rx
580 was first released we have a new her
ex 582 review technically this GPU was
released in June of 2016 so almost two
years ago now and the worst part is back
then it could quite easily be picked up
for two hundred and forty dollars us
which was the MSRP anyway let's not
dwell on that any more than we have to
and take a quick look at as rocks rx 580
phantom gaming XOC to see if it has
anything new to offer and how it stacks
up against the premium RX 580 models out
of the box as rocks factory overclocked
RX 5 ready comes with a mild 3% increase
in frequency
hitting a boost clock of thirteen
hundred and eighty megahertz
the gddr5 memory has been left stock at
2000 megahertz effectively allowing for
a transfer speed of 8g bits
second the real differences though can
be seen we're looking at the PCB and
cooler all the phantom gaming graphics
card to rely on PCBs ankles developed by
asrock the higher-end rx 570 and 580
models pack larger coolers featuring two
fans as well as an aluminium radiator
with a copper base and three heat pipes
asrock claims to use premium thermal
paste as well and double ball bearing
fans to maximize the lifespan and
efficiency of the cooler then in an
effort to maximize compatibility all
graphics cards include a DVI output
DisplayPort and HDMI outputs in order to
connect all kinds of displays tearing
down the cart is extremely quick and
easy as just six screws are needed to be
removed doing so reveals a fairly
compact PCB featuring a six phase vrm
which is fed power via an eight pin
power connector that's pretty standard
stuff really the cooler itself was also
quite compact and in total weighs just
384 grams so don't expect the phantom
gaming to offer class-leading thermal
performance the Auris RX v 8 extr for
example packs a 647 gram cooler and
you'd better believe that almost 70%
more metal to dissipate heat with makes
a serious difference I should note that
there's also no backplate included and
in total the carb measures 280
millimeters long 127 millimetres tall
and 42 millimeters wide making this a
dual slot card so let's quickly put the
Phantom gaming to the test and see what
it's got all testing has been conducted
our corsair GPU test ring powered by the
core i7 87 hero cake locked at 5
gigahertz with 32 gigabytes of ddr4
3,200 memory all results were updated
specifically for this video and we have
tested with the latest version of
Windows game patches installed along
with the latest display drivers ok
let's get in the results first up we
have Assassin's Creed origins and here
the asrock rx 580 spat an average of 51
FPS at 1080p using the highest quality
in-game preset this made it 1 to 2 FPS
slower than premium models from MSI and
gigabyte much the same we've seen at
1440p and here the asrock Eric's 580 was
a whisker faster than the old msi RX 480
and as you'd expect 15% faster than the
RX 570 trying at battlefield 1 at 1080p
with the ultra quality settings so
smooth eighty-eight FPS on average when
using as rocks new rx
580 graphics card again this was a few
FPS off the pace of the MSI and gigabyte
models which feature much larger coolers
still the asrock model remains strong at
1440p and again delivered playable
performance which is pretty typical for
an rx 580 in this title far cry 5 is a
well optimized title it was sponsored by
AMD and here we see the azrog rx 5 ad
matching gigabytes Oris gtx 1060 with 77
FPS on average which is comparable to
the other rx 580 models tested as well
although we failed to exceed 60 FPS at
1440p the performance was still very
reasonable and again the phantom gaming
was on par with the tricked-out GTX 1060
packin dying gigabits per second gddr5
memory
unlike Far Cry 5 Fortnight prefers
hardware from the green team but having
said that the RX 580 graphics cards do
well enough pushing over 60 FPS at all
times with maxed out settings at 1080p
even at 1440p the performance was decent
though for this fast-paced action
shooter you really notice the difference
between rendering over 60 fps and
rendering less than 60 FPS using maxed
out quality settings these graphics
cards breezed through our Rainbow six
siege benchmark and the asrock rx5
adding managed to deliver over 100 FPS
at all times when playing at 1080p even
at 1440p the RX 580 phantom gaming
provided well over 60 FPS at all times
and was roughly on par with models from
MSI and gigabyte finally we have
vermintide 2 and here the rx 580 and GTX
1060 GPUs provided very similar
performance the asrock phantom gaming
did only match the MSI R X 480 but that
did put it within 1 to 2 FPS of the
other rx 580 models tested moving on to
operating temperatures and here we see
that the thermal performance wasn't
anything overly impressive as we
expected given the size and weight of
the cooler hitting 74 degrees made the
asrock model 2 degrees hotter than the
msi model and three degrees hotter than
the massive gigabyte card given the size
and weight of the cooler those aren't
bad results but it did mean that the
bigger coolers on the msi and gigabyte
cards did ensure slightly higher
operating clock speeds here's a quick
look at the operating temperatures in
this stock out of the box settings as
you can see when playing around
Wars Battlefront 2 against some BOTS we
saw a peak temperature of 74 degrees
after 20 minutes of gameplay for
headphone users who don't really care
about operating volume you can track the
fans up to 100% and this reduced load
temperatures to just 61 degrees again
after 20 minutes of gameplay using the
OC mode which we will look at shortly
increase the operating temperature by
just a degree but it also increased the
fan speed by around 400 rpm so the card
was noticeably louder again if you don't
care about operating volume and then
cranking the fan speed up to 100% with
the OC mode enabled does drop the temp
down to a peak of just 66 degrees and as
a side note this configuration did allow
us to average over 60 FPS at 1440p with
a minimum of 52 fps after a 20 minute
test the other issue you faced when
using a small heatsink is increased
operating volume as you are required to
move more air over the smaller surface
area we see this with the asrock phantom
gaming rx 580 which hit 50 decibels on
our meter which was positioned half a
meter away from the system in a quiet
room the other graphics cards are all
tested under the same conditions on the
same day and we see that the only model
to generate more noise is the super
noisy AMD references own vega 56
graphics card anyway as Rox RX 580 isn't
ridiculously loud when under load but it
could very easily be heard over the rest
of the system and was noticeably louder
than the MSI and gigabyte models when it
comes to power usage the asrock rx 580
is more efficient than the MSI and in
particular gigabyte models a drop total
system consumption down by 12% that's
quite impressive given that it was never
more than five percent slower this just
goes to show how a graphics card model
used for representing the power
consumption of a GPU can really impact
the results in this case the Auris RX v
8 extr
did so quite negatively finally just a
quick look at overclocking and included
in the bundle is the asrock phantom
gaming tweak software which looks and
feels very similar to the MSI
Afterburner software using this software
you can quickly enable the OC mode or
silent mode or you can just do some
manual overclocking you can also monitor
and tune the fan speed increase the
thermal and power limits as well as
monitor GPU and memory usage it's in the
little tool that works very well
enabling the OSI mode increased
performance by 4% and far cry 5 and this
place the asrock Eric's 580 just ahead
of the gigabyte and MSI models then
manually overclocking the court at 1.5
gigahertz and boosting the memory to 9
gigabits per second increased
performance by 10% over the
out-of-the-box configuration so solid
overclocking performance from our sample
but unlike the MSI and gigabyte cards
which are extremely quiet when
overclocked the asrock rx 580 is a bit
of a jet there you have it the new
asrock rx 580 phantom gaming a mediocre
graphics card that you'd probably expect
to sell at the base MSRP if graphics
cards sold at the MSRP at all although I
compared this model to extreme models
such as the gigabyte or a Radeon rx 580
XE r 8g or the MSI Radeon rx 580 gaming
x 8g I expect that it will take on the
more mundane version such as gigabytes
rx 580 gaming or MSI's rx 580 armor for
example I'm assuming as much anyway as
the phantom gaming graphics cards I get
to go on sale in the US or Australia for
now as Rob tells me that availability is
limited to Japan Korea Thailand and
Latin America
I haven't said when they expect them to
hit our shores so I can't really say
when you better get your hands on one if
you're a fellow Aussie as I said earlier
right now you can expect to pay around
three hundred and fifty dollars u.s. or
about four hundred and ninety dollars
Australian for a base model rx 580 and
well I'm hoping this is where as rocks
phantom gaming rx 580 will slot in if
and when it becomes available of course
I guess the big question right now is
should you buy a Radeon erics 580 had
all right now
and today's inflated prices which are at
least $100 u.s. over the MSRP
I'd say unless you're extremely
desperate just hold off for now as I
said we will be seeing a new GPUs arrive
later in the year and with a new supply
of GPUs it is possible prices will come
down to the MSRP it's possible not sure
it will happen but I remain hopeful
anyway as a quick side note the RX 580
and GTX 1060 remain very competitive and
modern titles so I would recommend you
forget about brand loyalty altogether
and the markets just too crazy for that
nonsense right now if you need to
rearrange GPU just get whichever one is
the cheapest and that is going to do it
for this one if you did enjoy the video
then be sure to the like button
subscribe for more content if you
appreciate the work we do here at harbor
on box then consider supporting us on
patreon thanks for watching I'm your
host Steve and I'll see you next time
[Music]